هي الدار البيضاء كبرى مدن المغرب من حيث
عدد السكان والمنازل الاله للسقوط ايضا
لقمه العيش تدب الحياه في المدينه القديمه
بينما يطل شبح الموت براسه من بعض ازقتها
منازل ايله للسقوط تهدمت واخرى هدمت او
اغنيت من سكانها
رافقنا عبد المجيد الذي يعاني واسرته
الفاقه الى داخل منزلهم واقع المكان تعبر
عنه الصوره هشاشه البنيان باديه وشقوق
تنتشر كالفطر في جنباته
ولد عبد الكريم وترعرع هنا ويتطلع اليوم
لسكن لائق بينما تتناهى الى مسامعه حوادث
متكرره لسقوط منازل فوق رؤوس اصحابها
ما عرفناش من
عشره الالاف من البنايات مهدده بالانهيار
في المغرب بينها اكثر من خمسه الاف بنايه
في الدار البيضاء وحدها يقول المسؤولون
المحليون ان السلطات تحصي تلك الاسر
المتضرره فتخلي المنازل لتهدمها قبل ان
تعوضهم بشقق سكنيه
اكثر من 4600 اسره من مدينه الدار البيضاء
لوحدها
تكلفه ماليه تقريبا 29 الف دولار كيعطي
منا المواطن فقط الثلث 10 الاف دولار
والباقي تتحمله الدوله والجماعات الترابيه
تقر الحكومه بوجود اكراهات فالبطء وتدخل
اكثر من طرف فضلا عن محدوديه دخل
المستفيدين عوامل حاله دون القضاء على
الظاهره فقررت تفعيل هيئه رسميه تختص فقط
بملف
عن الايه للسقوط علمي زانيا اللي غادي
ترصد الوكاله باش يمكن ليها تشرع في العمل
ديالها والعمل ديالها غادي يكون حاسم لان
مايمكنش يبقاو المسؤوليات والتشتت بهاد
الشكل
وتتواتر حوادث انهيار المنازل في الاحياء
القديمه بعدد من المدن المغربيه خصوصا في
فصل الشتاء فتتسبب في خسائر بشريه وماديه
بعيدا عن التعقيدات البيروقراطيه يتطلع
سكان المباني الايه التي لسقوط الى تدابير
حكوميه مستعجله تبعد عنهم شبح الموت وتكفل
حقهم في سكن لائق المختار